cent soixante dix huit actes de violence
et d' outrage par jour contre nos
policiers et nos gendarmes ils méritent
le soutien de la nation et non la
stigmatisation comme vous l'avez fait
renoncement à combattre le
communautarisme islamistes renoncement
rompre avec le laxisme pénale de madame
taubira renoncement à construire les
15000 places de prisons promis ce
renoncement à placer en rétention de
sûreté
les djihadistes sortie de prison
monsieur le premier ministre la
situation est grave quand allez vous
enfin agir pour restaurer l'autorité de
l'énergie depuis bientôt trois ans vous
nous affirmer cook préoccupation
principale sur la clarté et la
transparence
et voilà que vous décrétez sans aucune
consultation que seuls les résultats des
communes de plus de 9000 habitants
seront pris en compte dans les résultats
nationaux par partie excluant ainsi 96%
des communes françaises du calcul et 54%
des électeurs
ainsi vous modifier la réalité du
terrain et camoufler la réalité entité
des listes pour la cinquième année
consécutive notre natalité baisse
ces mauvais résultats de notre natalité
sont on le sait les conséquences des
attaques en règle menée contre la
politique familiale depuis quelques
années et que votre gouvernement
continue à mener abaissement du quotient
familial fin de l'universalité des
allocations familiales réduction du
congé parental
autant de mesures qui dégradent au
quotidien la vie des familles des
classes moyennes et des classes
défavorisées
les attaques répétées contre la famille
comme cellule de base de la société
contribue aussi à cette chute de la
natalité
ainsi quel signal désastreux en verriez
vous avec le texte sur la bioéthique
si l'institut et dans la loi le mensonge
d'une filiation sans père après bordeaux
nantes lyon perpignan agen marseille une
nouvelle coupure géante d'électricité a
touché hier le val de marne
là encore cette coupure a été revendiqué
par la cgt énergie comme une action coup
de poing contre le gouvernement mais
encore une fois ce sont les français qui
sont un peu
t il est surréaliste qu'une poignée
d'individus comme et en toute impunité
des actes aussi dangereux pour annoncer
ensuite publiquement et tranquillement
dans les médias que de nouvelles
coupures vont intervenir et ce soir deux
cent mille personnes ne savent pas si
elles dormiront dans la rue ou dans un
centre d'hébergement
quoi qu'il arrive cinquante cinq mille
d'entre elles dormiront dans la rue
faute de centre d'adapter ou faute de
place ils sont issus d'horizons divers
vous les croisez chaque jour sans même
vous en apercevoir certains se cachent
pour se protéger pourtant il mérite
toute notre attention
non contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
entendre sur vauban
ces gens ne dorment pas dans la rue par
choix mais parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autres choix
on se félicite de l'action de l'abbé
pierre ou de coluche mais à quand de
l'état avez-vous bien mesurer l'ampleur
de cette crise la souffrance et la
difficulté des conditions de travail des
médecins des infirmières des aides
soignants confrontés au manque de moyens
au manque de personnels menacés de
beurre note parfois ne sacrifiez pas
notre santé est faite de l'hôpital une
priorité urgente
alors allez vous continuer d'accompagner
ce naufrage où allez vous enfin prendre
conscience des difficultés et sauver
notre système de santé
vous voulez absolument imposer aux
français la retraite par points de ce
fait pour le mode de calcul des pensions
vous remplacez les 25 meilleures années
par l'ensemble de la carrière c'est
votre logique ce changement porte
préjudice à ceux et surtout à celles qui
ont connu des carrières hachées
cela porte préjudice à ceux qui ont
galéré en début de leur vie
professionnelle
cela porte préjudice aux agriculteurs
qui certaines années ont vu à revenus
très faibles voire un revenu négatif
ces mauvaises années sont désormais
hélas pour ses différents publics
intégrés dans le calcul de la moyenne
des revenus ce qui aura pour effet
d'abaisser cette moyenne
[Musique]